Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here is a smart caller. This caller
thinks he may know the truth about
the latest Trump indictment. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. I think this indictment of
trump on seven plus counts is just a distraction
from Obama gates. I mean, there's still so
many unanswered questions and there's such a
mountain of evidence about rape that to like,
why are people focusing on things like sexual
assault charges and stealing classified documents
when instead they could be focusing on Obama gate?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Obama gate is the biggest
crime of the century. I don't know of which
century. Maybe this one. Maybe last one. It's
never really clear. Obama gate is extraordinarily
serious. I also don't know what it is.
And clearly, all of this stuff that's going
on, you know, a jury finding Trump responsible
for sexual assault and defamation of, Carol, a 37
count indictment involving pictures of classified
documents around Trump's toilet like a fort. All
of it is a trumped up, for lack of a better term,
distraction from Obama gate, which they don't want
you to know about. All right. Let me put my brain
back in on the bonus show today. The Supreme Court
has unexpectedly upheld a provision prohibiting
racial gerrymandering. Some are surprised by
it. Unabomber Ted Kaczynski has died in prison,
reportedly by suicide at age 81. We will
discuss the story and his legacy. We will
also talk about the White House being accused
of flag code violations because of their Pride
month display. This is getting so pathetic from
these folks who have no issue putting the flag
on a bandana that says MAGA and doing the exact
same thing. Now all of a sudden they're concerned
because of the pride flag. Okay. All of those
stories and more will be on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: The United States will be the
first nation to land an astronaut or NAS.
Speaker 1: We are taking the bonus show to Nas
and beyond. You can sign up at join Pacman dot
com. You can use the coupon code. Indicted again.
That's right. Indicted again. A self-explanatory
coupon code. Use it. Save a bunch of money.
Get the bonus show. We will see you that.